it is Friday which means I've got five
of this week best stories to get you all
put up on what's been happening in
gaming
bungie have said that necromancy could
be making its way into destiny and there
were originally for classes in the game
Bungie said they're considered
necromancy as a new warlock subclass in
the taken king but opted for the Warlock
stormcaller instead the necromancy
abilities would have let said warlock
resurrect fallen enemies as minions
understand directions but as a storm
calling you get lightning attacks so
it's not a great loss Bungie have
suggested the necromancy could pop up in
the game at some point though and also
revealed that a fourth class was
originally friend but was cut due to
overlaps with the other classes
new Mass Effect Andromeda details drop
to this week and since by where have
said the next two gameplay cliff is a
ways off it's probably best we make the
most out of it senior development
director Chris wind says that
Andromeda's combat will be similar to
Mass Effect 3 but with new elements that
make it more dynamic when also confirmed
that since the new game takes place in a
brand new galaxy it's unlikely we'll be
seeing familiar faces from the previous
games that said you shouldn't feel too
out of place because the hopefully not
too bumbling mako is back and there will
be a mix of both new and familiar alien
races from the nasturtium universe Xbox
exact crew dos uno de said some very
flattering things about the xbox one
this week including that the console can
do things that can't be done on
competing consoles like the ps4 sonoda
told games industry international that
cross play and cross by with PC as well
as backwards compatibility are giving
the xbox one a leg up over its
competitors he said it's a really unique
value that only we can offer you still
need very gamer focused value but
there's lots of things you can do with
our technology we've really got a lot
more going on than our competitors we're
doing things that can't be done on any
other console to noda also praised Xbox
for its upcoming exclusive
Sony Japan drops a new trailer for Metal
Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain this week
which emphasized that the game will be
concluding the series of narrative the
trailer explores the 28-year history of
the stealth franchise and shows off the
dark and bloody snake with the phrase we
have yet to learn why a legendary hero
of sunken into people ending with a
montage of the previous games logos and
the words finally the conclusion will be
told the phantom pain launchers on sep
tember 1 / pc and sony and microsoft's
last and current-gen consoles this week
xbox boss Phil Spencer said that Xbox
backwards compatibility could one day
extend to working with original xbox
games when asked on Twitter very silly
question but if Xbox one essentially has
xbox 360 emulator how much work would go
into making original Xbox titles
backwards compatibility Spencer replied
I don't think it's silly I'll go
backwards compatibility team this
question a lot need to finish 360
backwards compatibility
let me know down in that comment box
which original xbox game you most want
to see come to current gen this week on
site I tell you about some atrocious
superhero movies on the chip Lucy goes
over hot stones chest and we tuck into
gears of war Ultimate Edition that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
this week as always let me know what
mattered to you and be sure to have
yourself a lovely weekend